der erste mai tag der arbeit in diesem
jahr demonstrieren für den frieden auf
den straßen nicht nur in berlin ist die
sorge vor einem flächenbrand in europa
allgegenwärtig und mit ihr der protest
gegen die politik der bundesregierung
gegen die lieferung schwerer waffen in
die ukraine ich habe angst wie nie zuvor
dass das weiter eskalieren kann und ich
glaube nicht dass russland klein
beigeben wird diese lieferung jetzt
dieses ganze dieser hype werden
möchte
in düsseldorf wird der kanzler ungewohnt
laut er verteidigt einen kurs den er
selbst erst wenige tage zuvor
eingeschlagen hat
ohne branchen vorteile
außer zeit gehören vor allem die grünen
müssen sich erklären die partei die aus
der friedensbewegung hervorgegangen ist
stimmt jetzt für die lieferung schwerer
waffen für manch ein grenzt das an
verrat die alte friedenspartei dass die
also den kriegskurs mitmacht das war ist
erbärmlich für mich sind die grünen
durch unten durch also ich verstehe es
nicht gerade zum beispiel anton
hofreiter und so die die also berührt
sie jetzt einmal die pazifisten machen
die alles für mich zeit mal so die
kriegstreiber wohnen sind
anton hofreiter hat eine scharfe wende
hingelegt von parteilinken zum streiter
für waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
ihnen wird vorgeworfen ein kriegstreiber
zu sein was sagen sie dazu
natürlich ist es überhaupt nicht schön
dass man sich gezwungen sieht dafür zu
plädieren jetzt schwere waffen in ein
kriegsgebiet zu liefern aber was ist die
alternative jetzt zur unterstützung der
ukraine die alternative ist russland
gewinnt den krieg gegen die ukraine
zerstört die ukraine setzt sein programm
der demokratisierung umsatz vernichtet
sprache kultur tötet unmengen weitere
menschen nach einer umfrage des zdf
politbarometers
unterstützen 56 prozent die lieferung
schwerer waffen
39 prozent sind dagegen die deutschen
uneins während das land weiter um panzer
und position bringt gehen in der ukraine
die kämpfe und das sterben unvermindert
weiter sind waffenlieferungen die
richtige strategie um den krieg zu
beenden
das ziel des westens sollte nicht sein
möglichst schnell aus dem krieg
rauszukommen das ziel des westens muss
sein die russische aggression zu
ersticken das ist das entscheidende und
das ist eben ganz eng verknüpft mit der
frage nach schweren waffen richtung
putin kann nur eingedämmt werden wenn
man ihn mit stärke begegnet es geht auch
darum die ukraine in eine gute
verhandlungsposition für das ende des
krieges zu bringen sowie der krieg endet
definiert wie der frieden letztlich
stattfinden wird das sind die grenzen
der die ukraine in zukunft bestehen wird
doch friedensverhandlungen zwischen den
kriegsparteien sind nicht in sicht
trotzdem un-generalsekretär görisch mit
vermittlungsversuchen vergangene woche
in moskau die gespräche ohne erfolg
als gutes weiterreist nachgeschlagen in
der stadt russische raketen ein putin
lässt waffen sprechen keine worte
bislang waren die
verhandlungspositionen russlands und das
interesse an den verhandlungen
außerordentlich gering und vielmehr die
militärischen angriffe wurden immer
weiter intensiviert momentan deutet
wenig darauf hin dass russland interesse
hat diesen konflikt zu beenden
stattdessen wächst die angst dass der
krieg auf andere länder übergreift
besonders groß ist sie in der republik
moldau einem nachbarland der ukraine in
der abtrünnigen region transnistrien hat
russland seit drei jahrzehnten soldaten
stationiert die befürchtung russland
könnte versuchen über odessa eine
verbindung nach transnistrien
herzustellen unterwegs im dorf doris
kaya der grenzregion
moldau ist das ärmste land in europa das
durchschnittliche monatsgehalt
umgerechnet rund 350 euro schon 1992 gab
es hier einen krieg mit russischer
beteiligung die erfahrungen von damals
sind noch immer präsent
pedro philipp ist hier geboren der
automechaniker nimmt uns mit zu seinen
feldern wo er für sich und seine familie
getreide und weintrauben anbau
wir haben felder gehören zum moldau und
dort die gehören zu transnistrien
deshalb müssen wir immer durch die
grenzkontrolle
pedro philips familie lebt seit
generationen in der region die vorfahren
sind hier begraben wie lange er noch
bleibt ungewiss das geht hier fielen so
[Musik]
diese tage gerade sind hart für uns sehr
hart
ich sehe hier keine zukunft mehr für uns
[Musik]
alle in transnistrien haben panische
angst natürlich haben sie das wir haben
den krieg 1992 miterlebt und wir machen
uns sorgen
wir beobachten sehr genau was in der
ukraine passiert
die menschen bei uns fliehen wohin auch
immer
vergangene woche in transnistrien wird
ein anschlag auf ein gebäude der
pro-russischen separatisten verübt
dieses video soll den angriff zeigen wer
dahintersteckt bis heute unklar doch die
sorge wächst dass russland solche
attacken zum anlass nimmt den krieg
auszuweiten
putin hat aktuell ein taktisches
interesse daran dieses gebiet zu
benutzen um möglicherweise auch von dort
aus aktiv in diesen konflikt mit der
ukraine einzugreifen wenn wir das
zulassen als westen das geht auch mit
blick auf auf moldau dann ist die gefahr
groß dass putin dies als schwäche
interpretiert und sich sagt ich mache
weiter
unterdessen gibt es auch in russland
selbst immer wieder anschläge wie hier
in brienz mehr als 100 kilometer von der
grenze zur ukraine entfernt die ziele
waffendepots treibstofflager und
infrastruktur wer die täter sind ist
auch hier unklar
in moskau warnt der russische
außenminister vor einer weiteren
eskalation vor der gefahr eines
atomkriegs
wenn die risiken tatsächlich beachtlich
sind sollte man vermeiden sie künstlich
aufzublasen es gibt viele die das wollen
die gefahr ist ernst sie ist real sie
davon nicht unterschätzt werden
das ziel der russischen nuklear
androhung ist in den westlichen
öffentlichkeit ein angst zu schüren
angst vor einem nuklear schlag
damit diese westlichen öffentlichkeit
eindruck auf die eigenen regierungen
ausüben die ukraine weniger zu
unterstützen das heißt wenn wir jetzt
sehr stark darüber debattieren wie
gefährlich das ist erfüllen wir fast so
ein bisschen das russische magazin
die fronten sind verhärtet
russland setzt seine angriffe fort und
mittlerweile benennt auch der westen
klare ziele russland müsse sich komplett
zurückziehen aus dem don was von der
krim aus der gesamten ukraine
unser ziel ist dass es sofort zum ende
der kampfhandlungen kommt dass russland
den krieg beendet und seine soldaten aus
der ukraine wieder zurückzieht russland
darf nicht gewinnen und die ukraine darf
nicht verlieren bislang ein frommer
wunsch im osten haben sie schützen
gräben ausgehoben die kriegsparteien
richten sich auf einen stellungskrieg 1
und der könnte lange dauern
momentan ist das für russland besser
einen schlechten krieg zu haben als der
schlechten trieben zu haben war ein
schlechter frieden würde heißen sie
haben tatsächlich ihre ziele nicht
erreicht aber ein krieg der vor sich hin
dümpelt aber nicht verloren ist und die
man immer wieder eskalieren kann ist aus
russischer sicht dann attraktiver
frieden ist nicht in sicht heute haben
russische kämpfer das stahlwerk in
mariupol gestürmt es war der letzte
rückzugsort ukrainischer kämpfer und
zivilisten in der völlig zerstörten
stadt